what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so um like last week we did the
rundown with Batman letting a guy burn
to death I don't know why that's funny
to me I don't know why I'm laughing
about the fact that Batman let a guy
burn to death because Batman never does
that it's man that's messed up like when
you when you say it out loud it's rough
man but uh this week we're gonna cover
one of the creepiest stories of all time
which is when like Billy Batson becomes
Captain Marvel like when he gets when he
gets his uh when he gets his powers his
orders like his original powers in the
Old West comics number two so okay so
history time uh weird I don't know why
did that little intro thing Gordon you
got to keep that you can't not do
anything with that you can't cut that
out this is like the most fun I've ever
had making a video okay so it's like
1938 right and like like you have a
Harry Harry donenfeld and Malcolm
wheeler-nicholson and they've launched
Detective Comics and they have the
Detective Comics line of stories and so
on and so forth like new fun comics
adventure comics whatever and they want
to launch a publication called action
comics but they have like no content for
it they hit the panic button and Harry
donenfeld goes to this guy Vince
Sullivan and he's like get me something
for action comics I don't care what it
is
she's like this whole time you had a
Jerry Siegel and Joe Shuster who've been
trying to get like eighty body to
publish the story of Superman like
United features send a kid in like all
these different publications so they
sent it into DC which is kind of weird
because they were they were basically
writing slam Bradley at the time who's
basically Batman without Batman without
like the cloak and cowl but like he does
all the other stuff like he beats people
up and he's not really that smart but he
beats people up and he's like a
detective but the whole thing is like
like Vince Sullivan is going through
like a stack of right ends and he's like
whatever man I wouldn't grab this
Superman whatever this is and just throw
it in there it was total like a total
half and Stan's as Superman got
published but Superman got published by
like a luck of the draw and just like
exploded like it was a craziest thing
ever and they're right he's like oh yeah
Superman is the coolest thing ever
so like two years later you got Fawcett
publications right like Fawcett
publications was making like newspapers
and like magazines or what passed or
magazines but because of the fact that
Superman like blew up the comic book
industry I mean you had like timely back
then which is like the predecessor to
Marvel but like Fawcett was like okay so
like we got to get in on this cash cow
because if we don't like we're gonna be
like some serious cheese so the
president of Fawcett publications goes
to you a couple guys who were working
there he goes to Bill Parker and CeCe
back and he says give me Superman
without Superman and they're like well
isn't that copyright infringement he's
like don't give a damn so like they
create this kid named Billy Batson
Captain Marvel alright do this kid it
was crazy how popular Captain Marvel was
people think Superman was like the most
popular superhero of all time he was
like he is now but like he wasn't then
like back in 1940 no no Captain Marvel
was the name of the game
dude he doubled the sales of Superman's
comics he could fly the four Superman
he had his own radio show before
Superman he's like the most popular
thing ever that's why DC sued him it was
it was insane how popular it was but uh
we have this kid Billy Batson and Billy
Batson is like like he's got problems
right I don't mean like like 21st
century millennial problems like oh I
got a major in something pointless and
now I can't find work I mean like real
problems like he's homeless
yet somehow he's got these crisp clean
clothes and he's wearing Chuck Taylors
but like he's selling newspapers and
like this old man and like a hat in a
cloak shows up and he's like hello
little boy
do you want to know a secret it's like
it's like the creepiest thing like so
like if this happened right now Paris
will come running out of the woodwork
they jump out of cracks on the ground
they start beating this guy over the
head with purses but it'd be the
craziest thing everybody hillarious
that's a WorldStarHipHop video that's a
video that goes viral so this this this
creepy old man takes billy batson
into the subway it's a little boy this
little kid takes him into the subway
station and Billy's like where are we
going and he's like just wait and see
so they hitch a ride aboard the magical
train that up here I guess was going to
Hogwarts so it's like the magical train
and like the magical train takes them to
like Adventureland which rides by like
this seven deadly sins which is creepy
enough if I'm like a little boy who's
like 10 years old and some creepy old
man shows that missus hello little boy
come with me I want to show you
something you know and I follow him 1
that's a problem because my parents
clearly screwed up and two there's no
possible way this can end well so the
train takes Billy Batson to the home of
an old man this is so creepy it's like
the creepiest thing ever it takes him to
the home of an old man and like the old
man's like I know everything about you
Billy Batson it gets even crazier like
it's even like more illogical after this
so Billy so how do you know my name is
like I know everything about you you
know I so like the old man just like
shafts the word Shazam and we ended up
having like Billy being shown that like
Shazam is
they're like letters that stand for
things like you know solace almonds
wisdom and like Hercules strength and
out Lass's stamina and Zeus is power and
Achilles courage and mercury speed he
does not get a kill ease heal which
would actually be kind of funny like the
one weakness of like Shazam or Captain
Marvel is like all you have to do is
just like shoot him in the ankle and
he's defeated let's shoot him in the
heel that would be hilarious like
imagine that like a fight between
between like Superman and and like
Captain Marvel and like it was beating
the crap out of each other like it's
like there's no hold bar like blood it's
like this bloody downright bloody fight
like teeth are missing all that kind of
stuff and Superman is like I've had
enough of this and just like squeezes
Billy Batson he'll he's like you know
turns back into Billy Batson that'd be
hilarious like this I would I would I
would die laughing if that happened but
anyway so this goes into the whole thing
where the old man's like okay so like
I'm 3,000 years old because you know you
can believe me I mean I'm I'm not just
some crazy man tripping balls in the
subway like you can believe me I'm 3,000
years old all right and I exist to
protect the world but I can't do it
forever so like you need to be the one
to protect the world so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna give you powers to
basically shout the word Shazam and
you're gonna have all these abilities
and you're gonna become Captain Marvel
and so like Billy Batson says the word
Shazam it turns it like this grown man
uh and basically and basically like like
becomes a hero now I'm gonna be honest
with you guys I mean let's let's let's
be truthful here ladies and gentlemen
let's be honest with ourselves folks if
any of us had this power like all about
you guys I'd pick up chicks like it dude
that's what I would do I would be like
Shazam and the hey girl what's going on
girl look at how handsome I am and I've
got slicked hair and I'm handsome and
good-looking and I'm strong and like
that's that's literally what I would do
I'll just like shout Suzanne and then
like walk into bars and just like pick
up chicks that's that's exactly what I
would do you think whatever you can call
me shallow if you want to that's exactly
what I would do I regret nothing
so anyways once Billy Batson learns he
has these powers the old man on acid
sends him back sends it back onto the
streets all right so the next morning we
pick up with Billy Batson who's like you
know selling his newspapers and reading
this story about some maniac scientist
that wants to like blow up the radio
system like the radio system because
there's only one radio system in the
United States well he wants to blow up
the radio system and like there's these
two guys who show up and they refer to a
guy as the boss so Billy Batson being
the detective that he is puts two and
two together it says
a scientist wants to blow up the radio
system these guys refer to a guy as boss
clearly they're criminals clearly
they're bad guys and they work for the
maniac scientists because you know 1940s
comic logic so like Billy Batson like
watches these guys go into like these
high-rise apartments all right and then
he goes flying into the high-rise
apartment that goes running in there and
he's like hey doorman like there's
criminals who just walked in here and
like like the doormen are like what
evidence do you have he's like one of
them were you know referred to a guy as
boss he'll and it's like okay this is
this kids crazy this kid's got nothing
it's like they boot him out of here
right though I do get out of here kid
kid ignores them goes running into
talked to a guy named mr. Morris who's
running the whole radio program
everything so why Billy Batson tells him
he's like hey look man some guys are up
to no good they're gonna destroy your
stuff I know this because I heard them
say the word boss and clearly that's the
thing only criminals the mobsters say
and so you know mr. Morris is like
whatever man get the heck out of here
but Billy is like okay look I'll make
you a deal man if I figure out what's
going on and if I solved this case will
you give me a job and you know and mr.
moore's is like yeah sure man like I'll
definitely give you a job so like Billy
takes off and he's like this sounds like
a job for Captain Marvel and like shouts
the word Shazam so like he shows up
inside of like this radio play so these
guys are getting ready to destroy all
this stuff and they're talking to the
maniac scientist and like Shazam shows
up grabs one of the guys and throws them
into the radio equipment I keep in mind
these aren't like prop boxes right these
aren't cardboard boxes and it's not
really even a wall he throws them into
radio equipment electricity just flowing
through these things it means like don't
care whether you live or die like throws
them into the radio equipment all right
the other guy goes Bolton for the
elevator you know tries to jump down the
elevator shaft and Marvel grabs the Rope
throws it down there brings him back up
and beats the crap out of him so he's
like no not only are you not gonna get
away I'm gonna beat the crap out of you
just for good measure and so like so
like then like the the maniac scientist
starts talking crap so Shazam like like
half the Marvel you Billy Batson he's
like ah he's like look the next time we
meet you know either it's gonna be
behind prison cells or you're gonna be
dead because I'm gonna kill you and I'm
like really Billy Batson you're just
gonna run up on an old man just kill him
that is not what you were taught Billy
Batson I know you know better than that
but like he's just like running up on
old folks and just killing old folks
because that's what Batson does I don't
know it's pretty messed up so mr. Moore
shows up all right and Billy's like oh
man yeah dude look at this man this is
crazy like look at all this stuff like
Billy Batson calls him up and he's like
hey man all your radio stuff got trashed
and like like mr. Moore shows up he's
like what happened and Billy's like man
I have no idea so obviously he just like
told a bold-faced lie and so mr. Morris
is like wah
you can do this on your own but because
of the fact that I said I would give you
a job if you manage to solve this case
then like the job is yours so the
question we have to ask is what's the
lesson we've learned like like just to
recap what happened in this story
there's a little kid named Billy Batson
who's homeless yet somehow has nice
clothes he's met by a mysterious old man
who's wearing a cloak which never ends
well he follows the old man into the
subway system where he takes a ride on a
magical train covered in stars and
shapes to meet another old man who's
clearly tripping balls and says you'll
have magical powers if you shout my name
and then he turns around and he trashes
a radio station after for whatever
reason believing that these guys were
criminals because they said the word
boss then to turn around and tell a
bold-faced lie
to another guy and be rewarded for that
is what we've learned from this story
this is Golden Age comics guys 1940s
comics this is the way the game got
played but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the robb cork
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]